good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
i am very pleased to welcome you to this
edition of our 2021 2022 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and
sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence and
biomedicine where each friday we enjoy
presentations from leading thinkers
about the promise opportunities and
hurdles associated with ai applications
in the biomedical sciences selected
participants in our biomedical data
science innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital
material for our culminating in person
grant project development workshop to be
held here in historic charlottesville
virginia
in june
i am delighted to welcome our speaker
today dr latonya trotter from the
university of washington in seattle
professor trotter is an associate
professor at the the in the department
of bioethics and humanities at
university of washington she is a
sociologist of medicine who studies the
existence and reproduction of inequality
in the medical workplace in her work she
takes an institutional view of ethics by
considering how social workpla and
workplace institutions shape the notions
of responsibility and our understanding
of what constitutes good or ethical
decisions by individual professional or
organizational actors she explores these
and other questions in her first book
entitled more than medicine nurse
practitioners and the problems they
solve for patients healthcare
organizations and the state in
continuing our
2021-2022 biomedical data science
seminar series theme litany's lecture
today is entitled promise or peril
algorithmic intelligence and racial
discrimination in health care provider
bias is a known driver of racial
disparities in healthcare delivery and
through minimizing provider discretion
applications of algorithmic intelligence
have been have the potential to reduce
this kind of bias but they also have the
power to further institutionalize
discriminatory logics throughout the
same mechanism in her lecture today
latonya will be describing how this
transmutation of medical authority
alters the institutional and
interactional context of the healthcare
encounter in a manner that raises new
versions of old concerns at the
intersection of bioethics and the
reproduction of racial inequality as
always we are streaming the suction live
and for recording by youtube and if you
are watching on youtube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially
selected 2021 2022 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for
latonya via the chat feature in their
zoom sessions i will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so for the
lecture and with that welcome latonya we
are so excited to hear from you today
thank you so much for joining us
ah well thank you so much uh for that
warm and generous introduction you know
you know speaking for myself i was
really pleased to be invited to give
this talk
and to have the chance to speak directly
to early career scholars who have so
much promise to do good work and to make
positive change
i don't however come to you as an expert
on robots or artificial intelligence
but i do have one or two things to say
about algorithms
because although algorithmic thinking
has gotten faster more efficient and
more intelligent so to speak the use of
algorithms in the medical workplace is a
fairly old technology
still i do think i owe you a bit of an
explanation about when and where i enter
this conversation so that you can better
understand what's to come
so i'm a sociologist who thinks about
the reproduction of inequality and
injustice
and so i come to the field of bioethics
as less a philosopher than a social
scientist
and as a social scientist i focus quite
deeply on everyday workplace
interactions
i see places like clinics and hospitals
as not just places where patients go to
have their conditions treated
but it's places where people go to work
so i'm less interested in abstract
questions of what one ought to do
and more interested in ascertaining how
workers understand what one might do
which is to say i'm interested in
understanding how choice sets get
created in the medical workplace
because day and night
workers in health care are making
decisions and some of these decisions
are mundane or routine and some of them
are life or death but all of them shape
patient outcomes and experience
and i'm particularly interested in
understanding
why it seems to be the case
that reproducing inequality is so often
the default choice for those decisions
because make no mistake that does seem
to be the case
because health disparities are a real
and robust finding
in the u.s context black people have
worse health outcomes than the white
populations
so you might want to know with a little
bit more specificity about which
outcomes exactly i'm talking about
and i can safely say pretty much all of
them
when i first started studying health
disparities this was one of the most
startling facts that i learned
because
whether you're talking about chronic
diseases like diabetes or looking at a
range of different forms of cancer on
almost every measure african americans
have a higher prevalence and a poorer
prognosis
and when you see the same trend for so
many outcomes it starts to seem unlikely
that there's a product of different
mechanisms
so scholars begin searching for common
mechanisms right and so in doing so they
turned their gaze away from the bodies
of individuals and their habits and
upstream to the level of structure
so scholars began looking at factors
that affect whole communities and
populations such as residential
segregation environmental racism and
differential access to quality k-12
education
now most of these structural causes are
produced outside the purview of medicine
in the medical workplace
except that is for racism itself
you have scholars like david williams
bruce link and joe phelan who have
argued that racism is the common
fundamental cause of both downstream and
upstream factors
and the place where racism is most
visible and impactful in healthcare is
at the level of the medical encounter
so we know for example that provider
bias is a real and observable practice
such that a patient's race is an
independent predictor of low quality
care
so when a 2005 report published and
produced by the institute of medicine
they found for example that race the
race of the patient predicted a lower
likelihood of receiving appropriate
cardiac care receiving kidney dialysis
or transplants or receiving the best
treatments for stroke cancer or aids
treatment and even when you hold
constant variables like insurance status
income age and severity of condition
these these relationships remain robust
now the most commonly cited explanation
for these differences in care is
implicit bias
so implicit bias is something that all
human beings do right our lightning fast
cognition relies on stereotyped rules of
thumb for its speed
but the shape of many of these rules are
not hardwired but are culturally and
socially produced
sociologist eduardo benia silva has
written about white americans penchant
of segregating themselves from others
and social life and housing education
informal socializing and family
formation i might add that this
segregation is achieved not through
peaceful preference but generally
through illegal or violent forms of
so
exclusion
bania silva this segregating behavior
has created what he calls a white
habitus
such that racialized thinking and its
associated biases go unchallenged
through intra-racial socializing or
meaningful relationships
so since white healthcare workers are no
less likely to have been socialized in a
white habitus
they come to work with many of the same
implicit biases as the general
population
i also don't want to leave out explicit
bias because although implicit bias is
easier to talk about and so it often
receives the most focus in the
literature and in the popular
works
but explicit racial bias by healthcare
providers is also a real and observable
practice
so quantitatively 22 survey whose
results were published in jama found
that 21 percent of patients report
having experienced an overt act of
racial discrimination
the qualitative data is even more
evocative
in her 2019 book invisible visits
scholar tina sax talks about the ways
that black middle class women navigate
the health care system and this book is
notable because again
she's focused on black middle class
women so class or access to health care
is not the predominant factor
and yet her respondents described in
gruesome graphic detail a lifetime of
healthcare encounters that ranged from
the uncomfortable to the traumatic
but i think it's important to point out
that racial ideology and thought and
practice is not as some may think just
the residual left over um from science
i.e it's just standing in for the
leftover unscientific beliefs
yet this racial ideology is often
implicated within the education and
training of healthcare workers
so sociologist ann warning did a 2012
study examining the way that scientists
write about and teach racial difference
and she found
that the idea that race is a
biologically real and relevant category
is alive and well in science
and so when providers in training are
poised to believe through that training
that race is biologically real then it
becomes easier for theories of racial
difference to take hold
and take hold it has
and it's
rather famous now 2016 study by hoffman
and colleagues they found that a
surprising number of medical students
and residents endorsed what they call
false racial beliefs such as that black
people have thicker skin than white
folks that they age more slowly than
whites and that they're more impervious
to pain
moreover
the study found that a belief in these
false beliefs
was correlated with medical errors in
pain assessment
and since pain assessment is a
diagnostic criteria for many conditions
and illnesses the potential impact of
these beliefs is probably much broader
than the pain assessment itself
and these findings refer specifically to
medical students and residents but since
medical knowledge is to some extent a
shared resource it's likely that nurses
respiratory therapists occupational
therapists also believe in at least some
of this racialized knowledge
and this is where the promise of
algorithmic intelligence comes in
because to the extent that racism is a
part of the medical encounter and is
reproduced within it it has the
potential ai has the potential to
disrupt its reproduction primarily by
reshaping the behavior of the provider
within the interaction
so explicit bias and diagnosis and
treatment will be much more difficult to
perform when there's an algorithm
alerting them
that they're not following the evidence
in terms of care
and when that algorithm is not just in a
published guideline but is rather
embedded in an automated tool but they
will have to affirmatively account for
if they
decide to deviate from that decision
which is another way of saying the
burden of proof will be higher when one
decides against the standard of care
produced by the algorithm
it also has the potential to reshape
implicit bias so we know from the psych
literature that when you make people
aware of their hidden or implicit biases
they're also better able to through
conscious action think their way towards
less bias
so the ai then becomes a part of a set
of cognitive new cognitive resources
that the provider uses
so not just through constraint but
through making them more conscious of
their incorrect bias decision
the ai then will have the potential to
alter
implicit bias
and finally there's the potential to
disrupt the transfer of racialized
knowledge
through informal cultural transmission
that happens both at home
through primary socialization and
through medical education
so as medical students and residents
learn to rely on algorithms the part of
their cognitive toolkit the influence of
racialized views from their upbringing
or as dispensed from professors or
attendings will wane
but in order for this promise to come to
pass
we do have to pay careful attention to
the perils
because it is i would argue an
unfortunate truth that the same
mechanisms that have the potential to
reduce provider bias may simply shift
the decisions to other institutional
locations where the source of the bias
will be more hidden and thus less
unaccountable to critique and change
so while ai promises to intervene on
provider bias it does so by decreasing
autonomy
so when you decrease the scope and
number of decisions that workers make
the sort of power embedded in those
decisions doesn't disappear
it simply moves
so one of the things that i hope to
illustrate today is that the places
where it moves to are sometimes
difficult to trace
to hold to account
and the decisions therefore more
difficult to intervene on and change
and also
although there's nothing particularly
laudable about provider bias right
the one thing it has going for it is
that it's not particularly efficient and
what i mean by that is that individual
workers are biased in slightly different
ways which means that the impact thing
is variable so if we think to that 2016
study that looked at um
racial the possession of racial beliefs
in med students and residents not all
students held those beliefs right and
holding those beliefs did not change the
decision-making of everyone who held
them
however when aspects of the decision are
moved from this landscape of individual
variability you may get less bias but
you may also get more efficient bias
bias with no variability such that
racial beliefs become in effect racial
facts
produced and reproduced with 100
efficiency by the algorithm
and finally
in my talk i want us to think about and
think through the conditions of the
worker
because one of the things that workers
do is participate
in everyday acts of resistance to
employer control right so when we think
about um algorithmic logics they're not
just shaping some kind of abstract
encounter but shaping the behavior of
employees through surveillance and
constraint
so when you have a society that is
structured so unrepentantly around
inequality
the sort of
spaces of resistance are often the
moments where workers
make a way out of no way
in healthcare they do this not just for
their for themselves but for their
patients
so i want to consider the healthcare
worker as not just a source of technical
work or a dispenser
of acts or activities that can be made
more efficient and less biased but as a
worker who improvises and through doing
so creates the ground for thinking about
and organizing a new reality
so in the remainder of my talk i want to
flesh out some of these particular
perils through looking at a series of
illustrative cases
so you know even though we're all poised
to think about ai as being something
that exists in the future i often find
it helpful to begin in the past because
often the things that we think are new
are actually quite old
so i want to start with a case that
probably many of you are familiar with
and that's the case of the spirometer
and i want to start with this case you
know not because it's really an example
of algorithmic thinking but it's uh or
decision making but because it's an
example of the efficient reproduction of
the kind of racial facts that often come
to underlie such applications
so i'm taking this sort of historical
analysis and understanding of the
spirometer from the work of historia
union lonnie lundy braun
her book breathing race into the machine
so this barometer the spirometer is a
fairly simple mechanical instrument used
in pulmonary medicine it measures lung
function it generates a value that
providers use to diagnose respiratory
diseases
but this tool the one that we use today
is an updated version of one that was
developed during the 1850s during the
era of slavery
it was originally developed as barometer
in britain to measure the lung function
of industrial workers white industrial
workers
but when it moved and technology moved
across the ocean and arrived in the u.s
it was taken up
by dr samuel cartwright
he was a physician that practiced in the
antebellum south and he had a key hand
in taking this technology and developing
for use here
so some of that development was
technical but really mostly it was
rhetorical
because dr cartwright was a proponent of
racial science he believed that the
racists were different and that black
people in particular were biologically
inferior to whites
so for example he is very well known for
arguing before during and after the
civil war that one measure of black
inferiority is that we supposedly had
weaker lung functioning
and he used this as an explanation of
why enforced labor
either
through forcing the work of the enslaved
or through the forced agricultural labor
that came after emancipation um he used
this to argue that this sort of forced
hard manual labor was not detrimental
to the health of black americans but was
actually good and beneficial for us
therefore legitimating our place in the
labor market in these places
so one of the things that i think is
really important to remember in talking
about this piece of technology
is that the spirometer was not a
clinical tool
cartwright did not use it to diagnose or
treat patients black nor white
he used it to literally produce race
a believer in racial science he went
looking for racial differences and when
you go looking for something you often
find it
so one might even say that in addition
to measuring lung function that one of
the core functions of the spirometer is
that it was used to produce racial
difference which for cartwright was
synonymous with producing a racial
hierarchy
so in her expectation of the case monday
bronze work
notes that there was disagreement around
the sort of use of the spirometer and
disagreement around the sort of basic
fact
or argument about
black americans having lower lung
function right and i think this is
really important when you're talking
about a historical case people often
project back in history that everybody
thought the same way in a kind of
backward ideology but even at the time
there was contention and disagreement
you had other white physicians who had
had the occasion
to evaluate the fitness of black
soldiers during the civil war
and instead of using heart rights
barometer they use chest measurements to
evaluate
fitness and they found no difference
you also had black scholars such as the
statistician kelly miller and the
sociologist w.b du bois both of whom
denounced both the ideology of the
science as well as the statistical
methods through which cartwright
apparently proved this racial
difference but
despite this sort of conflict and
disagreement disagreement it was
ultimately cartwright's perspective view
and racial ideas that won the day
and not just his day but ours as well
because of course between the 1850s and
now the physical apparatus of the of the
spirometer has certainly changed and new
more accurate data has been collected
since that time
but the racial fact that black people
have lower lung capacity than whites
lived on
unchanged well after cartwright was dead
and buried
such that today
150 years after cartwright's original
flawed work
every time a person performs this test
or interprets the results they become
implicated in reproducing this racial
fact
and more generally generally they become
complicit and reproducing the idea that
black people's bodies are categorically
different than other kinds of bodies
so it's no wonder that medical students
hold fast to their racial beliefs
because while some of their racial
beliefs are labeled to be false
others appear to be standard medical
practice
so i wanted to go over this fairly
well-known case in part because it's
more than an example of race norming
but because i think that it illustrates
three things
first i think it shows us how easily and
seamlessly the past can live through the
present and part by obscuring the
existence of the past
so in this particular case
you know i highly doubt that there are
very many nurses pulmonologists or
respiratory therapists who perform this
test who have any idea about cartwright
who share his ideas about slavery or
share his racist ideas
and yet every time they participate in
this act race norming they become the
unwitting mechanism for cementing his
legacy
which means that the encounter which is
supposed to be a medical encounter
remains vulnerable to other interests
because cartwright was not just a
physician with some mistaken ideas he
was an active proponent of scientific
racism and spread his ideology through a
rigorous public defense
of slavery he was someone who made it
his life's work to perpetuate racist
biology and he used his barometer to
reproduce that racist ideology through
reproducing race
so when we look at the contemporary exam
room
although it may seem that the only
people in that room are the provider and
the patient we have to consider the ways
in which cartwright 2 is in that room
he's there through the tool he helped to
create and popularize
in in his presence he has also become a
decision maker a remote an unavailable
dead decision maker but a decision maker
nonetheless
so
the physical provider in that room
may be racially biased or not but the
decision has been taken out of their
hands it's the machine
not the provider who decides whether to
reproduce this racial fact
you also have the reality that the power
to resist
has largely been taken from the patient
because while a patient can disagree
argue or challenge sort of visible
racism of a provider
they cannot do the same with
cartwright's racial ideology
he's a decision maker who's invisible
and unaccountable but who acts with near
100 efficiency
such that the meaning nature and even
the actors in the encounter have been
changed in ways that matter for medical
care medical knowledge and medical
decisions
i also wanted to look more closely at a
second case that's less historical and
more recent
and that's the case that looks at the
measure of kidney function
which is the estimate of globular
filtration rate or the estimated
filtration rate so gfr is a measure of
how fast a person's kidneys filter blood
so lower kidney filtration rates suggest
worse kidney health
and worse kidney function
so since 1999 race was a variable that
was used in this calculation
and what happened in 1999 was that there
was a single study published which found
that black people in the study had
higher kidney filtration rates on
average than than whites at the same
blood creatinine concentrations and it's
the sort of measure of creatinine
concentration that is sort of the one
that's race norm if you will in the egfr
you also had a second study in 2009 that
found similar findings
however critics of this sort of race
norming of gfr have noted that race is
not an explanation
it's merely a proxy for something that's
not very well understood
as scholar benjamin asserts
race is itself an algorithm
which is thought to stand in for all
kinds of unobserved factors um
for example some have some have
hypothesized that the sort of racial
difference um in creatinine clearance
can be attributed to muscle mass but
others have asked well if that's the
case why not just measure muscle mass um
but neither and in the in the 1999 study
or on the 2009 study
neither of these measure
this explanation or any other
explanatory framework so race
is an algorithm being used but it's a
really poor algorithm
one that seemed to distract us from
looking for other kind of explanations
and the intensity of that distraction
has been quite fierce and the two
decades since the first study there have
been scientific articles opinion pieces
task forces convened and on the ground
organizing to change the use of racist
calculation
but a whole host of scientists and
physicians were publicly resistant to
making this change
and the failure failure to make this
change matters
because unlike in the case of the
spirometer
the measure of gfr um
in the brainstorming of it could
literally mean life or death for black
people because this is this measure is
the primary one um through which
eligibility for dialysis and kidney
transplant are determined
which if you know the epidemiology of
kidney disease the implications of this
are horrifying
35 percent of all chronic kidney
sufferers in the us are black even
though we're only about 13 of the
population
so race norm gfr systematically
underestimates the prevalence and
severity of kidney disease which is to
say that even though we suffer more
we're less likely to meet the criteria
for a kidney transplant or dialysis or
other interventions
because the racial fact produced was
that black people had to have a higher
number to register as having the same
amount of illness
so when it came to determining resources
black people had to meet a higher bar
a study
by malika mindu and colleagues
estimated that if the race correction
were removed
an estimated one out of every three
black patients would be reclassified as
having a more severe stage of chronic
chronic kidney disease and up to one
quarter of black patients would have
been reclassified from stage three to
stage four of the disease which is the
final state of kidney failure
to trigger more advanced care
and this is just one of many studies far
more than the two that set the standard
if there remained resistance to changing
it and in fact you know individual
hospitals began changing their
organizational standards first
mostly because of political organizing
and pressure by med students and
residents
a uniform change in the standard did not
happen until last year
and so i wanted to point out this
example
for a few reasons
first it's because unlike the spirometer
it doesn't just produce a racial fact it
normalizes on equal treatment
and it very efficiently distracted folks
from the very real very observable
social fact that black people were dying
at higher rates from kidney disease and
we're waiting longer for transplants in
part because of this measure
so it's almost as if this brainstorming
literally blinded people to inequality
and therefore left them free to
reproduce it and to protect its
reproduction for 20 years
and this isn't the only example um in a
2020 article in the published new
england journal of medicine
this article analyzed um you know 13
different clinical algorithms that use a
patient's race in the calculations and
it found that in every case the result
was to lower the quality of care that
patients of color receive
and finally i think this case
demonstrates the dangers of algorithms
and used in this sort of
institutionalized context because once
they've been institutionalized and how
people understand the disease i.e once
this sort of racial belief becomes a
racial fact um
right it becomes very very difficult to
change right
so there were assuredly fights about the
science
but make no mistake
it's expensive to change organizational
practice
and with medicaid being the primary
payer of dialysis and kidney transplants
i put money on the fact
that ponying up more funds to increase
care for black patients was part of the
institutional concern and change
so although one study produced a change
and a second legitimated it it took
scores to finally shift on the landscape
and to finally make um a comprehensive
change
and you know i honestly would argue that
even that change wouldn't have happened
without a political movement headed by
students
i also think it's a really good example
of why any conversation on rationing
health care should be really wary of the
promise of these so-called ethical
algorithms
some bioethicists have focused on the
promise of ethical algorithms feration
and care um in much the same way that i
talked about the promise
of algorithms to sort of reduce provider
um bias in reproducing um racism within
the healthcare encounter um you know
which is that clinicians obviously carry
biases that they bring to these kinds of
decisions um and if we had some kind of
algorithm that might make care and the
rationing of care more just
i.e you know the algorithm can eliminate
biases and provide consistency for
rationing decisions
but you know the egfr example should
really give us pause
in wanting to rely on the ethics of
algorithms because the so-called neutral
data going into these calculations were
a product of a commitment to seeing and
finding racial difference
and therefore so is the result right and
consequently it naturalizes the
conditions that might lead to a group
being deemed a sicker and less likely to
respond to treatment so if that is one
of the measures being used and
determining
whether to provide care to an individual
or not right um these sort of
pre-existing health disparities then
become
the reason why
future and further health disparities um
then are reproduced right so just like
heart rights production of race
might obscure
the environmental
sources that produce poor lung function
in in black adults during the antebellum
south such as higher rates of asthma
such as exposure to um
to
industrial byproducts such as
poor housing right
his production
of these sort of racial statistics sort
of obscured all of those differences um
and so similarly an ethical algorithm
that uses for example data that comes
out of pre-existing health disparities
can hide how health disparities actually
happen
and the way in which
so there's a way in which we can think
of these algorithms as potentially
holding patients accountable for the
harms perpetuated against them instead
of focusing our attention on the real
target um
so you know lastly i really wanted to
sort of zero in
on the specter of worker resistance
um because you know i'm preparing for
this talk i looked at all of the kind of
corporate and institutional ads sort of
touting the use of ai and health care
and when you do that everyone really
focuses in on the level of the
primary form of that relationship
let's be real is through surveillance
and constraint um
and the idea right is that the
surveillance and constraint will have
the effect of disrupting um
bias right but it also can have the
effect of disrupting forms of resistance
that employees engage in
so before i talk about the implications
of ai um
in the ability of workers to resist
i want to actually sort of talk about
two examples on existence of resistance
so one of these examples comes from my
own experience my own field work
when i was working on my first book
i spent a lot of time with frail
older african-american adults
this population of older adults needed a
great deal of support
to remain living independently in their
community
and so one of the supports that was
really crucial for maintaining their
independence was the assistance
of the support of a home healthcare aide
and i'll never forget the first time i
sat with a man who i'll call mr franks
the first time
i i met one of his aides i admit i
didn't pay much attention to what it was
that she was doing
but i did notice at the end that mr
franks had to sign off on everything she
had done
um so she'd been at his house for about
90 minutes
but the form that her agency used for
reimbursement from the payer clearly
stated that she was supposed to in this
90 minutes have bathed mr frank's
perhaps helped him shave
did light meal prep cleaned up after the
meal prep and engaged in light
housekeeping um
i don't know
if any of you have ever tried to make a
meal clean up after a meal clean a house
bathe and dress an adult in 90 minutes
it really was an impossible task
so i watched the aide sort of take the
form and use her pen and check off all
the boxes even though she had done less
than half of all the things listed and
she turned the form over to mr frank's
to sign
so my first thought was is she taking
advantage um because i watched her and
you know i knew that she hadn't done the
things that the forms that she had done
but i began to sort of keep paying
attention as this aide and others
returned day after day and i came to a
different understanding of what they
were doing
the forum was an attempt at surveillance
and control
and it was attempting to hold the aid to
account for doing what was really an
impossible job you know moreover the
sort of constraints of even the 90
minutes were very very difficult for
many of the aides to manage
aides who relied on public
transportation
would often arrive late for their
appointments because the agency
really only gave them 30 minutes to go
from half to house and if you've ever
tried to take public transportation from
place to place 30 minutes is never
enough
so what had emerged was a kind of give
and take all right um
so mr franks for example um didn't just
want someone to microwave a store-bought
um
frozen meal which is really the only way
that light meal prep could be a part of
the goals attained in 90 minutes he
wanted someone who would cook
so sometimes an aide might spend 45
minutes to an hour cooking up an
elaborate meal that mr frank could eat
for several days
sometimes an aide trying to manage her
transportation woes would actually cook
the food in her off hours bring it with
her right um in order to sort of try to
manage um the sort of friction of travel
she would sort of trade this time in and
out so
in trading with mr franks
he traded in something that he valued
for something that he valued less for
him
housekeeping was not really his concern
outside of the kitchen this was
something that was very rarely done by
his aides
but here the aide and mr franks were
making
a way out of no way through negotiating
the form
both of them are agreeing to mislead the
agency and the payer that had dictated
that all of these tasks could be done in
90 minutes
this act of resistance of course could
only be and exists because the form was
a fairly poor and inefficient means of
surveillance
but this act of resistance was also an
act of care
right the aide could have done the
aspects that she wanted to do
but she prioritized helping mr franks
get some of his needs met within the
impossible constraints of her work
so you know when we move up from the
home health care aid all the way up the
chain of command um
you know we sort of arrive at a set of
workers who we expect
to make autonomous decisions right so in
here i'm sort of referencing the work of
idea harvey wingfield and her book
flatlining um where she interviews and
spends time with black healthcare
workers in order to understand their
experience working as racialized people
in healthcare
and what she found is this
that health care institutions
participate in racial outsourcing
relying heavily on black doctors nurses
and techs to do what she calls equity
work
extra labor that makes organizations and
their services
more accessible to a diverse population
of people
she also argues that these organizations
because they become more profit driven
have really come to depend on the work
of black healthcare professionals to
perform this equity work
to increasingly diverse patient
populations
but
this work
is usually and almost always done
without recognition compensation or
support
but
when they take on this equity work the
workers do get some satisfaction and
doing what i call sort of improvising
resistance to the systems that reproduce
inequality
when they find themselves having the
power to do so they protected black
patients from institutional racism
and they also work to keep the kinds of
institutions that served low-income
populations that cared for their
community
so even in the face of constraint they
marshaled resistance and they marshaled
resistance in ways that were specific to
who they were as individuals not just as
physicians who would make the same
decision no matter the patient
so i began this talk by asking um that
when it comes to ending racial
discrimination and health care is you
know algorithmic thinking does it
represent a promise or peril
and now i can confess that this framing
was a little bit of a misdirect
um because from where i stand ai on its
own is nothing but peril
not because i'm afraid of the future but
because i understand our past
no algorithm intelligent automated or
otherwise is going to rid us of racial
inequality
so in the last few years we've seen
the appellation of new
to a host of new analyses um so you had
michelle alexander's book that came out
the new jim crow
in reference to the ways in which the
prison industrial complex reproduces
this jim crow system right through the
sort of prison system more recently
there's rue benjamin's work the new gym
code that looks at how algorithms in
tech are reproducing racial inequality
within its code
and these are both important reads in
part because they reveal that what was
old is new
because what was old has remained right
so the racial logics that drove samuel
cartwright in 1815 to defend slavery is
not only embedded in this barometer it's
embedded at the core of our social
institutions
but i think there is hope for the future
but it won't be in the specifics of the
code or in the data or in the way which
is applied
it will be in changing the social
relations themselves
so i started out this talk by
positioning myself as someone who seeks
health care as a workplace
that's because in many ways it is
but
the kind of workplace that it has come
to be doesn't have to be the kind of
workplace that it is in the future
so much about what the application of
algorithms or the broader suite of tech
solutions in healthcare are about
surveillance and constraint
which to me these words sound exactly
like the industrial workplace right kind
of like an amazon warehouse where the
work is boiled down to a set of tasks
and the workers are surveilled to be
more efficient and carrying them out
but that isn't the only way of thinking
about the work because the work could be
described as producing care
so when i describe the case of mr franks
and his home healthcare aides i chose
that example for a reason
because you know in the sort of
stratified world of home healthcare a
home healthcare aid is the lowest status
low in paying position where no one
assumes that workers have or deserve to
have any autonomy or independence
but what if we understood these aids as
not simply dispensers of work or doers
of task but as someone with expertise in
care
and someone who has expertise in
creating caring relations which is what
i found that mr frank's aides and
himself did under stressful conditions
if we saw that the encounter in the same
way that mr franks and his aides did
what different data might we collect
not because the data is better or more
accurate but because it reflects a
fundamentally different rendering and
value of the work the worker and
therefore the patient who's being cared
for
i also chose harvey ringfield's book on
black health care workers to point out
that these black physicians nurses and
and techs actually know quite a bit
about how to go about making the system
better for their patients
and so i want to leave you with the
thought
what if instead of extracting value and
free material and emotional labor from
these workers we saw them as sources of
knowledge and expertise
and finally
one of the things that algorithms do
is that it systematically hides many of
the actors who shape these relations
so when thinking about the illustrative
cases that i talked about i want to
point out that part of the reason why
they could be analyzed and critiqued
is because the data and the algorithmic
logics that produced them were freely
and publicly available to historians to
med students and to patient advocates
but the future of ai however promises to
be proprietary because our health care
system is proprietary right so it won't
be cartwright in the exam room it'll be
a tech firm
and when questions are raised about the
ideology that produces these algorithms
there will be no response except one
carefully crafted from the marketing or
pr department
so the real peril of ai then is that we
will continue to reproduce the same
social relations built on inequality and
an imbalance of power favoring corporate
elites because the peril is not in a.i
it's with us
so with that i will close um and i guess
open the floor for questions
latonya thank you so much that was
fantastic i really appreciated
all those little elements that you you
kind of
brought to our attention and perhaps you
know we haven't really thought about in
terms of you know the interactions
between health care and race and the
standards of care is suggested by
algorithms and one of the things which
kind of intrigued me was the notion that
you brought up about the the bias
shifting where these biases kind of like
they get embedded into the system and
they just get kind of propagated along
and no one ever asks like why they're
there and they just become facts and
then we just come to expect them and i
was i was also intrigued because you
were pointing out these different uh
examples of where some of these things
have embedded themselves i was curious
if you were familiar with the um the
science of cranion
craniometry which is the um
it was a a technology if you will from
the mid to late 1800s which was
considered very sophisticated in its day
it was the device used to measure the
lumps and bumps on your head to make
inferences about the functional areas of
the underlying brain structure and this
was used all over and in fact those
little phrenology heads that you can buy
and you know on amazon for about 20
bucks
those are really the product of that
um which is you know now kind of a
debunked science but it was used in
those those days to actually
justify the and measure and then justify
the inferior intellectual inferiority of
black americans um justified beliefs
about their um their criminal tendencies
their employability and importantly
education and it just took
the residue of this now debunked and you
know misapplied science which seemed
very sophisticated took decades for it
to wash out of the system we're still
kind of dealing with its effects today i
was interested if you knew about that or
if you had any other examples of where
that kind of thing has happened
um you know
there are ways in which sort of the
racial science of the of the 18 and
1900s was really quite prolific and
really quite productive
um
and so i am sort of familiar um
i hadn't
sort of referred to a sort of craniology
i'd heard it sort of mostly called um
the sort of phenology the sort of
production um these sort of racial
differences through looking at one's
head and i i think you know for me
you know um
the thing that that becomes really
interesting about these things because
there's ways in which when you sort of
go back in hindsight and look at these
there's ways in which the um the sort of
process um through which people believe
that they were producing good science
seems vaguely ridiculous
but i think the thing that's quite
amazing is the ways in which murkiness
becomes precise when you are using um um
data and algorithms right um so you're
taking something that
seems really quite murky really quite
problematic really really difficult to
reproduce but the moment you put a
number on it it is suddenly transformed
into something that's precise
and something that travels right when
you sort of create sort of
data
on which either theories or algorithmic
decision making are
overlaid the data itself seems to
produce
legitimacy through the production of
precision so there's something where you
know numbers are almost a rhetorical
device um right so you could talk for
example you know about you know
particular theories um that underlie it
people may debate the theory but the
moment you produce numbers there seems
nothing left to debate
um
and i think that that is you know again
you know one of the things that um
you know troubles me about the idea of
data being proprietary and the sort of
algorithmic logics being proprietary um
is that it becomes very very difficult
then to sort of unpack um you know um
the sort of rhetoric of precision um
that seemed to sort of be overlaid here
yeah i i
i totally appreciate that and one of the
things which is
i think maybe helpful maybe you can
advise us on is
how do people who are developing
algorithms they're basically they're
going to be the future of ai and that's
you know the people who are
participating in our activities really
what can they do to see it coming and to
kind of you know
understand it and recognize it and then
to try and you know tack the other
direction to counterbalance those
effects
yeah i mean i i thought about this sort
of idea of having something hopeful to
say
we appreciate that but i think sometimes
the difficulty
is believing or asserting
that these sort of
structural underpinnings can be improved
through an application or through a tech
a piece of technology but there's
there's something that um
um you know
we look we look at this you know the you
know the example that i talked about
spirometer right we look at the ways in
which you know 150 years later
um you know um you know um
even though the the technology of the
spirometer right um has certainly moved
and shifted over time um the raising
which ways in which we did not actually
see any movement in the in the the
actual sort of you know racial fact if
you will um that got reproduced and um
and so i think that for me
one of them is really right thinking
about
um
you know
the importance of the publicness of
these algorithms um or the or the logic
underneath them i mean i do not think
there's any way that a proprietary
algorithm that is not open um to
you know folks thinking it through um
you know
with community with scholars with
advocates advocates um you know really
have a sort of hope of um of really sort
of not producing these racial logics in
part because they're embedded in us
right um the things that our society
produce produces reflects who it is that
we are and if we haven't grappled with
our own sort of racialized thinking and
our own racial logics everything we
produce is going to reproduce
um the society and so really you know
honestly i think it takes um you know a
community of people thinking um through
these kinds of logics i think you know
in the sort of um you know in the sort
of broader community for example um of
folks
who are sort of you know thinking about
sort of
racial data um and their use and sort of
tech
and algorithms outside of the healthcare
there really has been a lot of sort of
ground swell of community organizing
around
you know being at the table and part of
being at the table isn't just to provide
ideas it really is about
the transparency
of you know what is happening so that it
can be critiqued and shaped so it really
isn't about you know the thing itself or
figuring out how to improve the thing
itself it really is about having these
sort of cultures of transparency and i
think the other way too is you know for
me one of the things reasons why i
wanted to focus
on
the things that workers know
is that we often don't know the things
that workers know because we never
bother to ask them because we don't
really care
if there's carrying out these stats
right but what if we did care right what
if you know we spent time right asking
them to help us understand how
some of the applications that are being
developed
may help them to better do their
job of their as they define it which is
usually not the efficient doing of the
work it's about providing quality care
and that really is a value right and
that's a value that is increasingly sort
of squeezed out of health care care
is increasingly absent and so if you
have
an absence right and a pulling out of
every shred of care under the guise of
efficiency
and sort of getting rid of individual
level variation and therefore bias right
um
you know you're you're not going to be
able to
create algorithms that actually are
going to reproduce the values of care
so
you talked a little bit about the past
informing the future
what sort of steps would you like to see
if they could begin today clinicians in
the healthcare
industry uh industrial complex uh what
could they do today to help start
mitigating any harm and disparity that
these algorithms are kind of uh you know
producing
yeah i mean i think that if you're
talking about the sort of level of
mitigation um you know there are
probably sort of more practical things
on that can that can happen you know
i've talked about transparency um i also
think that it matters um who's at the
table um so you know again you know one
of the reasons why you know i sort of
focused on what it is that workers know
um
is that i don't actually think we have
enough sort of bread and butter
providers um at the table um in the sort
of development of these applications um
you know i think we have providers who
are involved but they tend to be
involved as entrepreneurs
um right
they don't tend to actually
be involved um simply um as a key
stakeholder into providing sort of
community care um
and so i really think that if you took
seriously um the experience that workers
have um sort of navigating this terrain
and ask them you know how
what would um a tool look like when what
would a sort of algorithm look like that
would make your work as you define it
and as you value it to be right what
would that look like um
because i think right now we are solving
problems as defined by employers
we're not solving problems as defined by
workers
and patience so if you ask patients and
and providers to talk about what
problems they want to have solved you
would come up with a very different kind
of end tool than if you asked employers
oh i'm sure you're right and another
thing which kind of
as you were thinking speaking i was
thinking about
the role of of trust and that the
embedding trust into the algorithms
which kind of made me think about what
can we do to encourage people of color
and from you know communities who are
not otherwise well represented in ai and
machine learning and algorithm
development how we encourage them to be
more participatory what can we do to
encourage uh people of color to you know
become coders or to take part in in
these discussions what can we do better
you know as you asked this question i
had a thought that i've never had before
um and one of them because i think you'd
often write this sort of quest to sort
of you know the sort of standard idea is
you know
encourage people to come to
community-based meetings and to sort of
ask for their input um and i think the
other thing is to sort of you know
encourage people to sort of enter in
to the terrain um through
um you know being employed by a
particular company develop a developing
ai or a particular lab developing ai you
know um
and those often are problematic right
because on one hand it is true that
having more diverse people around the
table um you know has the potential to
sort of create more um diverse ideas you
know one of the the difficulties and
problems with always asking for example
lay community members to sort of show up
um is that you know
the experts at the table they're getting
paid for their time the community
participants are not
right
they're ways in which right
always being asked to sort of be
involved in your spare time on one hand
is nice but on the other hand is the
burden yeah sure and i think the second
you know issue with sort of you know you
know maybe having sort of murderous
first faces sort of employing these
organizations is
if i'm an employee of an organization i
may look like the community right and i
might try my best right to sort of speak
on behalf of the community but i am also
a worker for this organization
right um and so one of the things that i
think would be an interesting um um you
know think that you know maybe it exists
um i know that we have um um some some
perhaps some organizers our people
who've been involved in sort of
community-based work in the audience um
is you know
allowing the community to pick an expert
to work on their behalf
one who was accountable to them and not
to an employer
but who has the expertise and the time
to sort of show up and do the work
i think that to me that would actually
be um a way of having
community input from these various
diverse communities
in a way that's respectful of their time
and for the person has independence on
autonomy as well as the expertise to
sort of speak on their behalf
latonya thank you so much we're at the
top of the hour and this has just been a
delightful presentation it's been
wonderful to talk to you and to to hear
your thoughts and to hear your vision i
i just thoroughly enjoyed listening to
you today and uh i'm sure that i'm
speaking for all of our participants and
everybody who will watch this moving
forward thank you so much um we really
appreciate it and to everybody who is
listening uh thank you so much and uh we
will wish you a great weekend and we'll
see you next week thank you